morning everyone so one morning to young
fish are swimming along when all of a
sudden an older fish swims by in the
opposite direction the old fish turns to
the young fish and says morning boys
how's the water the two yo fish smile
and nod swim on for a little bit and so
one of them turns to the other and says
what the hell is water so the author
David Foster Wallace told this story to
the graduating class of kenyon college
in 2005 the point of the fish story he
told students is that the most immediate
important realities the ones that shape
our existence that sustain us are often
the ones that are the hardest to see and
to talk about so I thought about this
story a lot as I was applying to the GSB
and trying to go to that question what
matters most to you and why I must have
written a dozen draft of that essay and
each one was more convoluted and more
awful than the one before at one point
when I couldn't answer the question I
turned to my friends and my family
thinking maybe they had the answer
that's right in true Silicon Valley
style I tried to outsource the answer to
it was obviously a very deeply personal
question and then just to make matters a
little bit worse I would go to the
admissions website and I would watch
videos of current students who would
talk about how much they'd love the
application process and in particular
how much they liked answering that
question what matters most to you so
maybe some of you feel that way but I
didn't for me the process was torturous
and the end product it was an
overwrought convoluted 800 words about
culture culture so I felt like I got
into GSB in spite of that essay and
definitely not because of it and so when
I got to GSB last fall I felt like a
little bit of a fraud I felt like I'd
tricked Derek and I also felt I'm
probably only the only one who feels
this way so clearly that's not true
clearly a lot of us have no idea what
matters most to us
and that's crazy right because we're
pretty smart and scrappy Bunch we've got
the answers to a lot of questions and
yet we can't figure out this really
simple question so I've got an idea a
monthly graduation speech and because it
was inspired by this fish story and
thinking about calling it what's water
so here's what I want to do every month
I want to bring an amazing speaker to
the GSB to give a commencement address
and this isn't just any kind of speech
it's a reflective speech in which the
speaker is going to reflect on their own
experiences their job their life
everything holistically and in
reflecting on their experiences they're
going to give us an opportunity to think
our own experience here at the GSB in a
different way so now some of you might
be asking yourselves a very good
question your solution is more speakers
so fair enough right there are a ton of
speakers here at the GSB and in fact in
preparing for this speech I looked up
who's coming over the next week or so
here's the list this is a full time job
right this is about 50 speakers if you
went to all of these speeches this is
all you would do here are the ones that
I'll probably go to either because
they're awesome like Vinod Khosla or
because I worked for them like Jane Chen
or because I find them interesting
because of their industry or whatever
but there are two people I'm really
excited about seeing two people that I'm
almost certainly going to carve out time
for that's these two our classmates gaya
and Jasper we're giving talk next Monday
so talk is awesome right because talk is
different from just about everything we
do at the GSB talk is an opportunity to
sit quietly for an hour try to hold off
on those cell phones and listen to our
classmates tell their stories to talk
about what motivates them what has
challenged them what continues to
challenge them and inevitably is I
listen to talk I think about myself in a
different way I reflect on my own
experiences here and how I might want to
shape them a little bit differently so I
got to thinking what if we could do
something like talk but with famous
people the kind of people that are on
this list the kind of people we invite
to events like view from the top but
instead of spending 55 minutes talking
about the strategic tactical moves
they've made to get to where they are
now in their career we've really honed
in on those five minutes the five
minutes where somebody inevitably asked
a question like if you had one piece of
advice for us what would it be and then
I realized that already exists it's the
graduation speech so now some of you
might be asking yourselves another very
good question don't we already have a
graduation speaker we do but in response
to that question I would tell you this
little story when i graduated from
pomona college i went to Poland for a
year and somewhere around late-september
early October I realized was getting
cold and then I realized was
get really cold and I'm a Californian I
hadn't bothered to pack my winter jacket
so good starving student I did what any
starving student with you I called my
mom and I begged her to send me my
winter jacket so my poor worried mother
she dutifully packaged up my winter
jacket and she sent it off by surface
mail so what my jacket arrived so we're
around mid-april the following year this
is a true story especially if you know
my mother you'll know is true and she I
took that Jack and I stuffed it in the
back of my closet I had no use for it
anymore so I would just ask you do you
really want to wait to the end of your
two years here at the GSB to hear this
kind of talk and do you want just one
shot at an inspirational speech a little
early sorry doesn't ignore that slide so
I was asked you to reflect on the word
commencement to commence means to begin
and in the context of the undergrad
experience a commencement address comes
at the end of the academic experience
but just as undergrads are commencing
their foray into the real world so I
think this makes a lot of sense right
because as an undergrad your experience
with the real world has been pretty
limited probably a couple unpaid
internships but the GSB is different
you're at the GSB we have this weird
real world school hybrid we're aware of
the real world at every moment whether
it be in the speakers that are coming to
campus the jobs that were worried about
the summer internships that we're
applying for we're under no illusions
that the real world is here and we're
constantly running trying to figure out
how to make best use of that sometimes I
feel a little bit like a cartoon
character in the cartoons i watch as a
kid cartoons like this one we're a
little gopher is running for a survival
on a conveyor belt running running
frantically and even as a kid I would
think to myself there's a clear escape
route like just jump off that conveyor
belt
so now as an adult as a GSB student I
like to think I'm smarter than this
cartoon gopher and yet I find myself
doing the same thing running from class
2a BBL to my club activity to a small
group dinner too busy to take a step
back pause and think about what really
matters to me so as I am today I'd like
to ask you for three things as I try to
make the monthly commencement address
what's water a reality here at the GSB
the first is this if you have ideas if
you have connections send them to me
secondly if you're super excited about
this idea and you want to get involved
i'm looking to create a team that would
actually make this happen I can't do it
alone and I don't want to so if you're
excited come and talk with me and
finally for the rest of you I just asked
for you to carve out time an hour a
month to listen to an amazing speaker an
hour a month to jump off that conveyor
belt an hour a month to take a step back
and ask yourself the question what's
water thank you